I came ashore with my men on d-day an  attack that took us to the borders of  Germany my surviving battalions were  stretched thin and him placed in sectors  I commanded deemed quiet none of us were  ready for the ar-10 as soon as the  clouds rolled in so did the Germans  my fence would wouldn't break with our  division scattered every company plan  was a desperate struggle but it bought  the troops the time they needed to  regroup then we launch the  counter-attack  Battle of the Bulge one of the largest  operations in American history but for  over 90,000 men it would be their last I  live with the tough decisions I had to  make what would you have done  you